hello everybody thanks for joining the
agri genomics session
the demand for high quality nutritious
food
is increasing so is the need
for environmentally sustainable
safe and clean methods to grow food the
agriculture industry is adopting
new technologies like the next
generation sequencing
to address this increasing demand and
the safety norms
next generation sequencing is of
advanced technology
that needs technical expertise to
understand the complex workflows
especially you need to understand the
genomic complexities
of the various plants and animals to be
able to develop
assays that are specific and sensitive
for
the breeding programs and the amount of
data that is generated on an ngs
platform is humongous
you need to have bioinformatics
expertise
to understand the data and use the
various pipelines
to interpret and use it in the breeding
programs
so that makes it very challenging for
the agri
industry to adapt technologies like the
ngs
at thermo fisher scientific we take
pride in our mission
to enable our customers to make the
world healthier
cleaner and safer in line with our
mission
we have been working with the agri
industry for decades
as technology enablers and solution
providers
we have multiple genotyping platforms
like the pcr
sanger sequencing the axiom micro arrays
and the ion torrent ngs platform however
depending on what is needed
and the type of application that the
customer is pursuing
the number of markers that they need to
genotype
is where we make the appropriate
recommendation
for example if one is doing early phase
discovery work
trying to look through millions of snips
or hundreds and thousands of genomic
loci
to pick and select and predict we would
recommend the axiom microarray platform
similarly if you're in seed qc
or trying to do animal parentage
verification
you would be using the quantitative pcr
the sander sequencing on the
and the capillary electrophoresis
platforms
however once you have
decided or identified on the relevant
markers that are
important and crucial for developing
your new breeds
and where you really need to scale up
your testing
you would like to scale down and and
identify a mid density range platform
so that you could scale up your testing
that is where
the agribusiness team has adopted the
iron torrent technology
and the amplici chemistry to develop
a mid-density platform called the
aggressive
targeted gbs solution
that can help the customer genotype for
known targets
in a mid-density range of 50 to 5000
markers
and the amplitude chemistry helps in
developing a multiplexing strategy where
you can look at all the targets amplify
all of them
in one single reaction for
coming up with the most appropriate
solution for marker assisted selection
or breeding
that the agri industry can use for
furthering or meeting the demands
the aggressive solution includes a
service
that our team provides in developing
custom panels for the known targets
we work with the customers in
identifying
the genomes of their interests and
develop these panels
further the addressee library prep kit
which is an adaptation and modification
of the amplici
chemistry to scale up and to make it
affordable
likewise we have developed about 1536
barcodes that enable high throughput
genotyping
we use the iron torrent gene studio s5
prime
and the chef for sequencing and
make use of the torrent sweet server
along with other additional pipelines to
provide the data analysis
and combining with the various sample
prep solutions that we have
like the magmax ad genomic core dna
isolation kits
we have a complete solution that you can
trust
thereby can move forward with a
with a total solution that would help
you
for your affordable breeding programs
coming to the agri-seq workflow it can
be
easily divided into four steps
starting with library construction
templating
sequencing and data analysis for library
construction
we start with 10 nanograms of dna as the
input
with the addressee library kit the whole
protocol is a six to seven hours
protocol which can be performed both
manually and
automated we do have a 96 well format
that works in both and a 384 well format
that can be fully automated
so once you have amplified your targets
prepared the libraries and barcoded them
those amplified barcoded libraries are
cleaned up and normalized
and then added to the iron chef along
with the templating reagents
for templating that happens overnight
and the next day morning you arrive and
take out the chip
out of the iron chef and load onto your
sequencer
for the sequencing no matter how many
samples
or how large is your panel the
sequencing always takes
only about two and a half hours and so
in a given day
you can easily sequence two chips in the
templating process the ion chef is
actually
able to template two chips therefore
your sequencing is also set up for where
you can sequence two chips in a single
day
which gives you a throughput of up to
3000 samples in one single day
and the data analysis follows the
sequencing and it usually takes about
6 to 24 hours depending on the
number of samples and the size of the
panel to convert all the raw signals
and and give it to give you the
actionable genotypes
and that is all seamlessly integrated so
overall
the workflow is pretty simple and mostly
is automated
and you can easily scale it scale it up
by adding automation one single
uh full-time person can actually
genotype up to 3000 samples using a
liquid handler
uh one sequencer and a chef
they can easily process 3000 samples in
a day
from data from starting from the sample
to
output the whole workflow is about three
days
to accomplish the aggressive workflow
solution
the data analysis from sequencing is
pretty seamlessly integrated
the gene studio system is where all the
sequencing is happening
and the raw signals are are recorded the
ion torrent server
runs the the torrent speed software and
all the
plug-ins it's a cloud-placed uh platform
that helps you run
uh in the i am torrent platform the
basic technology is that
as uh every time a nucleotide is
incorporated
according to the template uh you are
releasing
a hydrogen ion is released as a
nucleotide is incorporated
and this release of hydrogen ion causes
ph changes
and changes in volt voltage which is
what is
recorded and once all these raw signals
are processed and linked to
what base was incorporated corresponding
to the time frame
and the change in the voltage meter is
how you
convert the raw signals into the base
calls
once the templates are sequenced
all these bases are then aligned to the
reference genome
of interest that was being studied and
the
actual calls are made and using plugins
like the array analysis and the tolerant
variant caller plugin
which is actually looking at the
presence or absence of the variant
at your hotspot or marker of interest
those calls are recorded and we
our team has developed the agri-sum
toolkit which helps you summarize
all of these calls and presents it or
helps you visualize
uh and makes it your
quick analysis or review of the data
very easy
and also further reformats this data
into a usable format that is
very uh helpful for your downstream
analysis so
at the end you get actionable genotypes
that you can
transmit or take it over to any of your
downstream analysis tools that can help
you
process your data so here's the sample
output from the addressum toolkit
it summarizes the data as you can see
here
uh it gives you the panel summary on the
left it tells you
what markers were in the panel uh how
much was the
overall coverage and overall mean call
rate it also provides you a quick
preview
into how the different markers in your
panel perform
and and how the samples that you've
tested perform
our team has used the simple traffic
colors
the green uh yellow and red green really
good
yellow is be watchful and red is uh
something has not worked out go check it
out and as you can see there are drop
downs
that will actually indicate which of
these
markers or samples failed in the runs
you further also get to see nice graphs
and charts
uh gives you a quick preview of how the
the
sequencing run was and how the
performance was
you can also get a graph where
you are looking at multiple parameters
in this example here you can look
how was the mean depth or coverage
versus the call rate
so you get an idea did the sequencing
run happen
as uh as you anticipated and was the
performance of the markers are looking
good or do you
really need to go repeat this experiment
it kind of
gives you a quick preview into your data
and at the end of it the agri-sum tool
could really facilitate
the uh the various formats in which you
need the data
the default format is genotype matrix
and then we've also
giving format like the top bottom which
is similar to the microarray format
and the parentage format that one would
use for doing parentage analysis
so uh the agri-sum tool it actually
makes the whole data interpretation
uh very easy and uh facilitates the
using of the sequencing data for further
downstream analysis
looking at the iron gene studio some of
the advantages is that it is easily
scalable and flexible
in fact here we are talking about the
plant and animal genotyping but the same
iron torrent gene studio can be used for
other ion ampliseq applications
for viral and bacterial typing as the
flavor of the current season is
the gene studio is being used to look at
the covet viruses
uh sarkovic viruses you could do rna-seq
methodologies and various meta genomic
applications as well
on the same gene studio platform but for
us for plant and animal breeders
the flexibility is also provided in the
various
type of chips that we offer which kind
of helps you
uh with your throughput we have the
smallest chip the iron 520
which gives you up to five million reads
where you can test a few
markers say like one plate uh up to a
small panel of up to 400
markers and about 125 markers and 400
samples
whereas most of our agri breeding
agri customers who are into the marker
assisted reading and selection programs
use our high throughput chips the ia in
540
and the 550 which gives them a range of
60 million to all the way to 130 million
reads
where you can look at markers ranging
from 100 all the way up to
5000 markers and depending on the panel
size you could always run anywhere
between
96 all the way to 1536 samples
so it kind of gives you a great
flexibility
in coming up or optimizing your
sequencing or genotyping workflows
which is what most of our customers
would like to see
that's an added advantage with the
platform so
overall if you look at agric it is a
very flexible
powerful and cost effective tool which
was perfectly designed
for agriculture especially for helping
the breeding customers it is flexible
because in one single panel you could
look at multiple types of markers like
the snips
the multi-nucleotide polymorphisms the
small insertions and deletions and other
structural variants
it you can develop assays that would
include all of these markers
you can look at multi-species panels in
the same run
where you actually would
develop libraries or amplify libraries
with
for each species and then combine all
those libraries and put them
on for the sequencing on the same
sequencing run
similarly it is very powerful because
the entire workflow
can be automated it helps you in
discovering novel genotypes because we
use a 200 base pair
amplicon you are also looking
at oftentimes you are looking at novel
genotypes
that the these torrent sweet uh
software automatically gives you uh
looking at the sequences that have been
genotyped
it is very cost effective because in one
single
uh pcr reaction you are able to
multiplex
for all the markers whether it is 50 or
5000
or even more in one single reaction you
are
you are performing a ultra high
throughput pcr reaction
similarly you're able to genotype up to
1536 samples
in one single run on a chip and you can
genotype up to 3 000 samples easily
in a single day thereby it is making
the whole solution very cost effective
so
once again we can conclude that the
aggregate
is a flexible powerful and cost
effective tool
that is being specially designed for
agriculture applications
so here's some data that we can look at
which kind of supports our claims that
agrees produces high quality genotyping
data
we have looked at multiple size panels
the first one on the left you can see
the bovine
200 snip marker panel which is the isag
recommended markers and we have
developed another
panel for poor sign with 1500 snip
panels
for one of our customers and in both
cases as you can see
the overall call rate and the
performance of the panel is really high
uh 98 for bovine and 96
for four sign we've also done several
uh intra runs and internal comparisons
and there
again we see that the uh the
in intra run and interim conferences
are pretty high about 99 and above
we've also compared it with orthogonal
technologies
out there on the market one of our
partners
uh tested the our panel our isa panel
and compared it with
and we see 99.4 percent concordance
between the
two technologies we further also looked
at
uh several plant panels working with our
partner europe and biodiagnostics
we had developed a panel for sunflower
for about
768 snips the samples were provided from
the
u.s grain repository where they had
samples with known genotypes
and so we compared the data between our
lab
and eurofins and that is seen in the
green and blue dots here and then
compared it with the data from
which was provided by the the grain
repository
and we see a very high level of
concordance between
all the runs so thereby we can say
between sites
and between runs as well as with
orthogonal technologies
the aggressive solution provides a
high quality data that you can trust
here's another example where we had
conducted a test for
the usda we were testing out
19 bovine breeds that are used for beef
and we were testing uh samples using the
eyesight bovine panel
and you can see that the panel performed
really well
the average call rate was 98.5 percent
uh across all the all the beef breeds
that we tested
so overall if you see we have been
continuously
uh using uh innovative approaches to
enable
agriculture research over the past five
years
since we've launched this product we
have
uh continuously increased the complex
markers that we are we are looking at
the complexity has increased from snips
to
multinucleated polymorphisms and
insertions and deletions and this year
we are we are developing panels with
structural variants
uh we have continuously evolved we have
increased the throughput from 384
barcodes
to 1536 barcodes by the beginning of
this year
thereby providing a high throughput
option for our breeders
likewise we have been continuously
working in improving our
analysis tools starting with the torrent
suite software
uh as i have shown you data on uh how
the agri-sum
uh toolkit helps in data visualization
and summarization
we have been working continuously
support our customers
overall we have also launched several
off the shelf panels like for isic
bovine parentage
last year in 2019 we launched the
gbs panels for canine and feline
parentage
and they can also be combined with
traits and disorders
so we have off-the-shelf panels that
customers can readily use
not only for parentage but also for
looking at various traits and genetic
disorders and defects
in these past four years we our team has
developed
over 150 plus custom panels
covering over 45 species in plant animal
and aquaculture
so you can believe and work
with our team so overall we are
dedicated to continuous
improvement we have been developing
various new applications
and solutions for agriculture as you can
see the various plant
crops that we have worked on including
vegetables
nuts and recently oil palm similarly
we have worked on livestock and
companion animals and various aqua
species
we believe in continuous improvement we
work with our customers
in trying to work on as for their needs
whether
including complex markers or coming up
with faster design tools
we are helping them with workflow
improvements
by sharing automation scripts and
coming up with the liquid handling
protocols
to help them automate the entire process
and we we work very closely with various
chaos across the world
in coming up with solutions that are
helping in advancing
agriculture and we are always open to
new collaborations
and looking for uh more partners uh
hopefully
after this uh the genetic analysis
virtual conference
we will get more partners to work with
across
the world and
please do check our website for the
various customer testimonials as you can
see we have been working with
great partners empowering global
agriculture
across the world and we would like to
see your name added here
definitely check out for the customer
testimonials and there's a lot more
useful information
on our website with that
i would like to take thank you for
attending this talk
and would like to take questions thank
you